and these are the nominees for best
animated feature film they're like okay
it's gonna happen after this commercial
and it's like oh okay and then they put
a camera right right there yeah suddenly
okay it's about to happen and the Oscar
goes to zootopia
instantly a State of Shock I think it
was kind of like blurry vision like okay
don't fall down my pocket is going crazy
because my parents are texting me my
husband's texting me everyone in the
world is texting me you should have just
taken it I know
it was surreal it was that feeling of
now I get up and my feet are taking me
to the stage and it's almost like an out
of body type experience yeah we are so
grateful to the audiences all over the
world you're trying to remember the
things you uh intended to say you're in
front of thousands of people you know
that it's going out to billions of
people around the world and it's all
happening in the blink of an eye and
then then it's over and then you're off
stage and then you're kind of just
looking at each other like I can't what
just happened did this really just
happen but then the moment really starts
to sink in because as you're walking
with that Oscar people come up to you
and they're congratulating you whether
they know you or not they say like
there's going to be a camera right
backstage you know that you can say all
those extra thank yous too when you
start to remember them you see that
camera immediately and I'm still not
remembering I'm even worse right now